oh good morning my name's Adam Smith
calling from Novell media in Stockholm
would it be possible to speak to James
Rothman please oh good morning professor
Rothman my name is Adam Smith calling
from Novell media in Stockholm we have a
traditional gosh you haven't had long to
do so what were you doing when the call
came from urine and what was your first
thought hearing the news I was
completely shocked and surprised
marvelous marvelous the truth is that
anyone almost anyone who receives the
Nobel Prize has some indirect knowledge
of one sort or another that they might
be a candidate and so you know at some
level is not a complete surprise but
that it actually happens is an
out-of-body experience and do you think
you're going to relish the onslaught of
press attention that follows this
imagine that's that's the big
opportunity it really highlights the the
field you work in so biology in general
no yet no I just tried actually I was
just on the phone with him he gave me a
call I do what I want to say that I'm
absolutely delighted to to share this
award with Randy Schekman and Thomas
sudo absolutely together you're credited
with taking the field of vesicle
trafficking from a descriptive to a
mechanistic level
and the citation describes that uses the
word machinery to describe vehicle
traffic is that how you think of it when
you think of the cell moving molecules
around in vehicles do you think of it as
a machine and the reason is that is that
one of the the major lessons in all of
biochemistry cell biology and molecular
medicine is that is that when proteins
operate at the sub cellular level they
behave and there's certain ways if they
were mechanical machinery it's
absolutely fascinating when you when we
when we study chemistry the chemistry
the rules of chemistry electrons and so
on they they operate it as even smaller
level of atoms and molecules but when
you get to the sort of level of the nano
scale you find that these objects start
behaving as if they were mechanical is
exactly how I think about it and I
always have it's a beautiful picture and
actually my orientation originally was
in physics I was trained as a physicist
busy young and what so attracted me
about molecular biology was the the the
the opportunity to find simplicity thank
you but and in in a week or twos time
when things are quite and down I hope
we'll have a longer conversation where
we can dig into this more but just one
question
what gave you the courage to embark on
this study in the first place because
the initial experiments were it wasn't
clear that they'd work at all no I don't
know you probably have the benefit of
the press release so I don't know quite
how the committee you know has written
this story but yes there were in the
earlier years when I
when I started this project it Stanford
University everybody told me that that
it was nuts to go and try to reproduce
you know the complexities of the
mysterious complexities that occur in
the whole cell in a cell-free extract
and but III and and my courage came from
three sources I would say the first in
all seriousness was youth because
there's a certain arrogance and in youth
I don't know if I'd have had the courage
to do that today
the second was the fact that you could
in those days in the United States you
could do adventurous things with very
little or no preliminary data and you
could still get support from the NIH to
do it and so in today's environment I
doubt very much and I would have had the
freedom or the opportunity to truly
pursue this in the third frankly was I
was inspired by a man named Arthur
Kornberg and Arthur Kornberg has a name
that should come up in your interviews
because Randy Schekman was Arthur's PhD
student indeed yes and Arthur as you
know unfortunately died a few years ago
was one of the great biochemists of the
century though the 20th century and he
was the reason why I was at Stanford in
the first place why I left medical
school and the opportunity to to be in
his department and have the lab next
door and the reason Arthur was such an
inspiration is that in his own time he
had conquered an unbreakable barrier for
free and zoology as he called it which
was the the synthesis of DNA and so I
frankly got a lot of cards encouragement
from being in that environment and
watching what Arthur and others could do
and it's a beautifully 16-ton so thank
you very much indeed
well as I say I was scheduled a longer
interview with you in the coming week
but for now I just should let you get on
with what will be an extraordinary debt
anyway good luck with your interviews
with the other laureates today and and I
look forward to speaking to you at
greater length but another occasion
thank you very much indeed pleasure to
speak to you and once again
congratulations